sollte manuel keine ahnung alle wieder
krieg ausgebrochen
auch im ring
hallo den krassesten feind überhaupt der
das hand und natürlich immens
ich habe gehört dass du mode gehen
welches motto ich habe übrigens sehr
lange nicht mehr aufgenommen und hier
noch meine schwulen freunde mit dem ich
eigentlich aufnehmen wollte aber dann
kann man weg 12 und kalibriert und habe
mir einfach den schwulen rotwild
weggenommen deshalb die angreifen
cri cri wie ich werde auf jeden fall
lustig er rege ich schwöre dir deine
ganze tastatur hat sich ja meine
schreibmaschine und du bist hässlich so
was machen du kannst du mir kommen du
kannst mir helfen
ich muss ich muss sehr wohl hier
einbauen was bauen ich muss mir selber
aber erst mal bauen
youtube ist ich mache mir habe ich
eigentlich noch hier fremd kakadu pizza
ich hätte ob die zu boxen
ich hab schon bock für die welt niemals
boxen alter und ich mache mache ich mich
näher ist mein brauchst dann boxen war
die haben nicht geboxt sagte auf krieg
hab ich nicht ich hab doch kann ich
nicht irgendwo das ist doch das ist doch
total erstmal danke ja dass ich hier
noch aluminium aber ich habe ja
geschrieben hatte ach so ich dachte
schon ich auch dass wenn die jetzt
angreifen weil ich bin erfreut pinkel
und welcher nicht mit mich würde wer das
geschehen
ich liebe dich aber ich glaube du musst
jetzt schon ein bisschen so
deeskalierend wirken ich habe mir
gedacht die bei ihnen war die nachricht
gut deeskalierend ich liebe dich ich
weiß ich weiß nicht warum das jetzt
irgendwie deeskalierend wirken sollte
wenn du aufstehst aber der klar ist ob
ich keine frederik kam er habe
eigentlich immer noch in stat pink in
dieser kategorie
in dieser kann gesagt okay wenn es ein
chat schreibst du pussy warte und ich
hoffe wieder eine tastatur ich habe mich
gerade jetzt wo ich wohne aber das
kannst du dir denn der folge zulegen
kann sich in der folge dann lesen weil
im endeffekt habe ich gerade dich ein
bisschen beleidigt was aber keiner aber
keiner weiß keiner weiß das update
jetzt will ich wissen was da steht
da steht ja bloß wissen wer der horst
der transport ist auf die abi ist der
der im arschloch sitzt bleibt student ja
ich komme jetzt bereite ich bereit mich
jahrelang auf dem krieg ging nicht vor
wachsen wachsen bisschen bisschen roxel
ein bisschen roczen box.de de de
denn du kannst du jetzt mal besuchen
kommt dann zeige ich dir hier so was ich
hier baue ich kann es dir mal ein
schwarzer gucken was denn hier ja schon
weiß 90 greiz machen wie ich weiß nicht
hat den debitoren portal zu uns kommt
also zu euch wie zu uns ja zustand blau
zu uns zu dem zu stadt lauf zu nehmen
hell wie kommen jetzt dahin ohne jetzt
irgendwie fox zu schieben
ich weiß wie du was wie komme ich gerne
zu ihr ich habe kein portal können bei
debitel nicht einfach was kaputt machen
oder davon ausnehmen
was wenn ihr zuge kommen will ich kann
er bei den flotten debitor ja sollte bei
dem etwas kaputt wo bist du denn gerade
das jetzt er willst du denn gerade das
das den einfach ja jetzt bin ich gerade
bei peter bei alfa sonstige räume klingt
einfach wie bei einer nackten männer
unter der dusche bis peter ich bin aber
ich hab ja gerne seid ihr denn sind
nicht gestattet
dieses under hier also ein turbo was
anders ist der stadt pink hey wir sind
gerade bei also ich bin gerade bei dem
auto mit den beiden mit dem brot bild
sie haben drohte romario ist habe ich
keine ahnung habe ich doch nicht
lucasville auf deine mutter dass du da
bist was du isst trinkt bist ich und in
shopping kommen bei mir zu hause
pink war luca hör auf du verstehst du
das einzeltier klatschen wichtig 122 das
ist okay okay
luca ok ok luca luka okay ich fungiere
jetzt dolmetscher für dich ja kriege
hier gerade eindeutige signale von
manuell empfänglich gesendet kann aber
nicht genau ausmachen was die mir sagen
wollen kleinster felix wiggers eine lok
drum und flüstert ich bin behindert er
flüsse die er flüstert im chatroom dem
transport
er hat mich angewiesen portal bei der
vitusstadt durchgehend kommt zu mir und
sagt mir wie ich hier weg kann alter
egal ich weiß nicht wo ich ohne scheiß
jetzt mal okay ich hab ja erlaubt was
ich mache ich habe mir gerade die
herbsten filme wo willst du luca fast
denn die sache ist sie wie wollt ihr
krieg oder wollte keinen krieg ich wäre
für keinen krieg aber dann lasst mich in
ruhe dann schreibt das den anderen
vereinbarten außerdem ist richtig wenn
die zu viert auf mich draufgehen moment
von vier hat keiner geredet was ich sehe
ja oder zutritt
ich will nicht dass du eben reingezogen
wird die sache ist nur sagt den anderen
dass ich keinen krieg möchte das musst
du dir sagen luca ich kann den satz und
enders ich bin in der königsball
nein der ist tot alle leute haben gesagt
dass du wohl clown willst des brutto wo
ist unser aha du hast jetzt sagst du er
sehe ich dachte die ganze show cobo also
unsere königin
sie suchen sich luca luka ich fange ich
an alle kräfte an alle kräfte alkohol an
zu brennen
in eurer stadt ich hab keinen bock auf
krieg 14
wenn wir friedlich leben und ich denke
was ich wäre damit einverstanden
oder war es allerdings ein spielchen
romano ist wie gesagt ich habe es jetzt
nochmal den gameplan aber standort für
richtig und muss sagen das gefällt mir
hier kann ich mir auch die kisten bei
dir was raus nehmen wir haben auch
friesen friesen friesen des wehres
friesen ich hab mal in der klasse die
sowohl die friesen und wollte mit dem
auto über die russische grenze fahren
bis ihnen dann die polizei zwei otto
weiter weiter geschnappt hat uns
wirklich coole gebracht hat das ziemlich
traurig luca wo hängst du sei ehrlich
jetzt kann ich bin gerade mit malte und
rotwild in stadtlohn ich war die ganze
zeit in stat appells auf pilze gesetzt
hast was gemacht
nix okay okay du bist du luca okay ich
sag mal so ich hab mir okay ich hab mir
auch alte deshalb hast du sicherlich
probleme mich zu sehen
also ich sehe gerade nur mal als auch
danke
wer dich sehe ich nicht wie es im ok ich
hab nämlich ablesen kleines icon was wir
erlaubt mich was zu verstecken ich werde
abgeschossen werde mich abgeschlossen
wo bin ich denn jetzt
man will keine ahnung krieg ausgebrochen
müssten gemacht
das geschieht hier mal ehrlich was was
fällt dir ein
was fällt dir einen drucker ehrlich mal
war er junge leute schießt nämlich ab
warum gegen mich jetzt wieso hast du
mich gerade abgeschlossen
kaum schießt ihr mich wundert dass
einige filme
ich will nur mein leben und oft hier
oben wird von zwei zuschauer verfolg
alter werden manuell alter neulich
verliere einfach über das leben durch
fall schaden der redenschreiber bitte
was ein chat von mir als dolmetscher ich
will jetzt nicht singen phillip island
wenig an alter verpiss dich fit auch
angegriffen
was machst du schwul was hat alter
meinten bei flugstatus kaputt läuft wenn
jetzt sehr guter springer bin ich tot
junge das ist mal mega pussy alters
schreibt das mal mit den chat das ist
mappus
vor allem die blauen 96 haben das
richtig verwirrend ich habe gerade eben
felix einfach nachdem ich wenig
geschlagen habe einfach mal marx meinte
ich also ich bin bis jetzt ganz fein
raus sachen geschlagen habe was passiert
hier einfach alltag das ist krank das
ist einfach nur gestört
ich versteh gar nicht was sie machen
sollen ich kann dir nicht helfen ich
kann ich meine eigenen staat kämpfen was
geht ihnen keine bringen ich kann nicht
gegen einen eigenen staat kämpfen
die kamera monster falle bewegen wir das
junge reh wie ich bin gerade mit einem
kampf anleger die abfahrt stolze gerade
meine fresse das nur ein bisschen level
fahren
wenn jetzt mal das sind drei leute was
soll wir machen
felix macht doch gar nichts wenn es nur
ums haus mit japan gehörten luca warum
felix war das alter gefragt es mir
natürlich ist einfach alle stelle jetzt
alle es reicht es vollkommen her ich bin
diesen staat viel zu oft einfach dass er
dadurch geputzt
nun ist ja noch
verzauberung skarke jung ich will jetzt
ihn töten ja was traust dich nicht weil
wissen zu krass denn wir sind statt bank
also wird jetzt auch krieg keine ahnung
habe ich daraus ich wollte nur so ein
bisschen die stimmung nicht im krieg
das ist ein bisschen keiner wird hier
theoretisch keine blöcke abbauen oder
willst du machen willst gehen machen
junge das hatten ja bitte verbogen
werden
ruppelt der im kasten bogen ich weiß ich
weiß nicht ob ich weiß wie wasser zu
tauchen offen
was soll denn die scheiße ich dachte ja
natürlich auf ein bisschen bauen noch
mal etwas gewusst
es kam er es eben kann er es vor der
aufnahme so dass sie gesagt haben ja wir
nehmen mit felix weiß ich schon meine
sachen und dann solle mich von mir aus
töten darf ich dich töten luca bitte
lass nicht dich zu töten
damit erhält erläutert oder kann ich
habe ich entweder jemand getötet der
verfall des ok wir treffen seinem walzer
machen wir eins gegen eins schwanz
fechten okay ich bin tot
ich hab euch respawn betrieb aus
versehen auf fakten kurz wieder auf fakt
jetzt hab ich's baum gedrückt
erst mal wieder sein reflex egal leben
ist aber die wieder direkt runter
gegangen
das ist das level gefasst ich hätte ja
bock auf kämpfen gehabt aber es war
einfach viel auf mich einfach das
laufende programm läuft
ich weiß nicht
aber wir stecken inhalte sowie schlecht
war der wald ist schwert verzaubert
die haben auch mein bett abgebaut oder
du kannst wieder drauf kommen haben wir
nicht ich bin am arsch der welt junge
wir haben david ich würde das geld nicht
weg ist bist du wirklich bin auch rasch
der welt ja ehrlich jetzt ja
wahrscheinlich kommen wird ich schwöre
auf mein leben ich bin am arsch der welt
ist auf jeden fall stimmt nicht im haus
wohl gestorben bist was mache ich denn
jetzt ich hab ja auch keine sachen ich
kann ich sterbe gleich wieder an essen
hilf mir mal die leute ihnen helfen
alter ich habe ihnen geld es
schokokuchen alles ich kann nichts
machen was mache ich denn jetzt scheiße
ich beende jetzt erstmal die folge
das mache ich denn dann alter ich
brauche auf jeden fall was zu fressen
was schreibst du eigentlich die ganze
zeit ich schreibe gerade was mache ich
denn ja das ist auf jeden fall das ist
auf jeden fall
das ist auf jeden fall statt
pink drei leute auf einen dass auf jeden
fall killer wie kriege ich denn jetzt
hier ich brauche was zu essen
wie kriegt denn jetzt was zu fressen da
musste ich kann mir nicht helfen
ich habe einen flug starben gefragt was
mache ich denn jetzt ist das hier
normaler pilz war schon okay ich habe
pilze das freut auch die anderen arten
von pilzen skelette wie komme ich hier
weg
und es ist mit 100 nachwende diese
psychospiel folge keine ahnung was ich
habe gar nichts gemacht einfach nur
anwesend
irgendwie ist das abfahrt kalter was
mache ich denn jetzt und hier sogar
aluminium halbe minute da war ich jetzt
mal das aluminium ich mache noch mit
dran bessert paris athen
ich wollte mal ganz schnell diese diese
kg ab wenn das geht hier jetzt eben mit
der schaufel okay es geht nicht aber
egal wenn ich jetzt meine folge ich bin
wahrscheinlich nichts vor gericht wieder
tun weil ich dann wieder in essen stehr
bereich von drei leuten die auf mich
drauf gegangen sind wurde innerhalb von
zwölf minuten getötet das ist irgendwie
ein bisschen keine ahnung ich habe auf
jeden fall alle meine sachen noch also
mit quasi nichts passiert nur dass ihr
morgen keine folge hero bekommt und
sonst